Penny Penny
Sheldon come in thank you I'd like to
make a sandwich but I'm out of bread
I'm in the fridge
keep your bread in the refrigerator stay
on this is caused by crystallization of
the starch molecules which occurs faster
at cool temperatures on Earth we'd say
thank you
that's the multi-talented actor Jim
Parsons who millions of viewers came to
love as Sheldon Cooper in The Hit CBS
series The Big Bang Theory the Emmy
Award winner is returning to the stage
in a new Off-Broadway production of a
man of no importance Parsons plays Alfie
Byrne a bus conductor in 1960s Dublin
who also runs the amateur theater group
out of a church throughout the musical
Parson's character wrestles with his
beliefs and identity Jim Parson joins us
right now bright and early how you doing
I'm very good how are you good good so
this is a an intimate setting yeah the
the theater seats around 200. yes um
what is it like preparing for something
as intimate as this show
um I I when I was younger in doing
theater I was in a lot of intimate
settings but it's been at least 20 years
or more since I've been in a setting
like this and as we near I was telling
Gail this earlier as we neared the
audience coming in I started getting
very nervous about it I did but I will
tell you as soon as they got in there it
felt very familiar and and I love it I
love it's not scary at all in that way
it's it's you were more scared oh I said
I was very nervous I was in seat b208
that if I wanted to I literally guys
could have reached out and touched them
that's how close we are I can happily
report that you have no fillings in the
upper part of your mouth that's how
close I was and you're I was surprised
that you're not thrown by that
um every and and you're on the stage
practically the entire hour and 45
minutes yeah no I'm not I'm not thrown
by it I really love it I um I
I don't know if it's this play or if
it's just me personally as an actor but
I I do enjoy we are about as close as we
are now yeah and um I you can feel the
the non-verbal communication as it were
of the story being told and them
receiving it and it's it's it's a really
sweet experience and it's a very sweet
play as far as it's it's a small Play
It's a small group of people in a small
town setting and that all kind of fits
in with that kind of intimate Vibe and
it's a great cast and you have to have
an Irish accent I do and you're from the
south was this hard for you uh uh well I
I like that you talk as if I've gotten
it perfectly so let's tell people that
yes it's gone perfectly and it was a
very big challenge but I've aced it
um yeah it was challenging I am actually
working with her name's Claudia Hill
Sparks she was my voice teacher in grad
school over 20 years ago and she coached
me through this you reached out and
asked for her to yes yes I asked I I
said I'll work with anybody but I have
somebody I love if if the theater
wouldn't mind and yeah they got they got
her to come what is the amount of time
that one dedicates to learning an accent
it's been it's ongoing
I'm still I'm still doing it um uh yeah
yeah it doesn't it doesn't stop um they
tease me I start talking in the accent
about 45 minutes before the show begins
I'll go over my notes in an Irish
dialect can we get a little sample of it
right now no you must oh you have to buy
it that's right
okay all right let's talk about what
people get if they buy a ticket uh you
say this play is about the magic of
being alive explain that
um yeah it's really about the magic that
happens when you really settle into who
you are and allow yourself to be who you
are and all the joys and slings and
arrows that come with that
um the other thing it's about that I I
think you know having seen it and it
kind of fits in this intimate setting
it's really about the magic of theater
and what it is to get together with the
group people and create something and
pretend to be other people that kind of
becomes real and uh I I've said again
and again whether you like this show or
not I think to see this show if you had
never seen theater before
you could become addicted to theater I
could see being like I must do this now
it's true true theater but we have to
talk to you about the Big Bang the cats
got together recently and they were
saying how crushed they were when they
found out that you were leaving and that
they felt blindsided did you feel number
one I think it's a testament to how
Loved You Are by the cast of course and
how loved it the show was by everybody
when you heard that they felt blindsided
did you that's certainly not your
intention no so what did you think when
you heard that Jim that they thought oh
that they nobody wanted that show to end
its scene right yeah
um
I I never feel good knowing that
anything I've even incidentally done
would make anybody feel less than good
so that never feels uh good to me I did
feel that I knew I was doing right by
myself with the decision and so
I mean you know what that's like there
are there are just things you have to do
in life sometimes you know it's right
for you and um
I don't know but but the cat but the
cast all got back together and sat down
for a book yeah discuss it and that
seemed to be a very good experience for
everybody to sort of relive those
moments because as we showed the clip
you said that was from the first season
yeah so it was a good experience it was
wondering well it was a rare experience
that I didn't realize I kind of wanted
which was the chance to spend upwards of
20 hours off and on talking with Jessica
radloff who wrote the book it was a very
interesting way to frame 12 years that
otherwise you wouldn't get the chance to
do and she would come back after
interviewing other people with
triggering stories and memories you're
like oh my God I'd forgotten about that
and or no that's not how I remember it
that person's crazy
um but uh it was wonderful it was
wonderful and listen everybody's gone on
to other things and everybody seems to
be doing all right yeah you're doing
great Jim thank you so much for joining
us we appreciate it thanks for having me
make sure you check out a man of no
importance